[Music]
Donald Trump is suing you now please you
had to know we were gonna talk about
this I know and Trump and I are friends
we've cut similar hair no you don't
well as long as you brought it up tell
them why he's sewing me well uh I want
to make sure I get the story straight
but you of course made a joke on your
show that that that you wanted him to
prove in the way that he asked our
President to prove that he was an
American citizen right you wanted him to
prove that he was not the love child
love child of an orangutan of an
orangutan because his looks and he
thinks a joke on a late-night talk show
is a is a binding legal agreement and in
the world of late-night comedy there are
no binding agreements you of all people
should know this that is so true it
takes a second to figure out what you're
this is healthy because it took me a
second to figure out what you were
saying like oh right right that you know
we're moving on yeah this movie I
remembered right
you moved on I was like I know exactly
what he's talking about but look I don't
have a trump with this man I mean he's
not even a real person it's just like a
pop reference from the 80s it's like
having a spat with jr. Ewing or Milli
Vanilli yes exactly I you know heat
tweets about me constantly he's like I'm
not I talked about that I did the one
bit and then I answered it on my show
Friday night because I had to say
something right and it was an epic
takedown if I say so myself but you know
basically let's move on to the other
topic which is that we should not be
having frivolous lawsuits like this
right they clog up the courts you know
the legal system in this country is not
a joke
it's not a toy for rich idiots to play
with it's it's not a collection agency
for billionaires you know and they
should have I think they should have in
the courts just like in the NBA they
have a no flopping rule you can't
pretend to flop right that's what we
need in America no right Wapping rule in
the court so you're saying that you know
do you think Trump is serious about
carrying this forward do you really
think he's serious about anything he's
just making noise he's gonna go away how
do I know what is in this man's head I
mean it's like they took Lenny from mice
and men and made him a billionaire
[Applause]
he's suing you for a kitten Oh George
but you have some skin in this game
because if he were to win which is
impossible he would never win but
anything said on a talk show could be
legally binding that's where I'm safe
that's where I'm safe I act like such an
ass night after night you come out you
you sort of carry yourself with some
dignity people think that you're saying
I do crazy dances and moves would show
30 seconds of that in court and the
judge would throw it out and say this
man's an idiot that's what I can get
away with anything because people think
I'm a man-child yeah you should try that
just try a little every now and then
just be like yeah like Charlie then you
say whatever you want
my advice